I heard that you had completely gotten
over nicotine and then I heard you met
Keith Richards of The Rolling Stones
is that true story that he got you
smoking again no I smoked with him like
I I knew I was going to be okay I think
that was when I interviewed him he was
at WNYC in New York doing one of their
shows so I was going to you know use the
studio and just go next it was so funny
because me and Brendan McDonald my
producer were hanging around WNYC
waiting you know and it's public radio
New York public radio right and all of a
sudden this woman comes running out into
the into the main area going he's
smoking what do we do he's smoking and
the answer is I guess you let him smoke
but uh I'm talking to Keith who's my
[__] hero you know I love Keith and
it was such a it was such a big day and
uh and he's smoking he's drinking his
vodka and orange soda whatever the hell
it is and I'm like what are you smoking
you know he's like Marvel you know I'm
like let me just hold one right so I'm
I'm like an idiot you know he's smoking
I'm just holding the cigarette talking
to him and at some point you know he he
literally throws a lighter at me and
hits me in the head and I know I'm like
right and I'm like I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna smoke with Keith Richards this is
the devil I waited for this is the guy
you have heroes in your life Keith
Richards when I was younger I wanted to
play guitar so I bought the same kind of
guitar he had I smoked Marlboro
cigarettes because I read in an article
that Keith smoked marble secrets I'm 14.
I started drinking Jack Daniels because
Keith was drinking Jack Daniels I mean I
got my hair cut once like it didn't work
out but I tried so but this is but you
know this is the thing about heroes so I
interviewed him not too long ago for the
re-release of main offender right it was
the zoom thing he's wearing this beanie
have you seen the pictures of him lately
he wears these wool hats and he looks
great I said to him I said you're not
hanging beads in your hair anymore and
he's like it was something to do but
anyways so so he's wearing this [__]
hat Howard and I'm like where'd you get
that hat I love the hat I pestered him
for 20 minutes where's the hat from to
the point where his publicist emails me
and says this is where the [__] Hat's
from shut up about the Hat
we're not advertising these things right
so I spend I spend all this time trying
to figure out what the [__] this hat is
I buy it's a 300 cashmere beanie all
right so I buy the Hat I put it on and I
stand in front of the mirror and I have
the same [__] moment that I've had
over and over with Keith Richards is
that I'm not [__] Keith Richards
that baby's not doing anything for you
exactly it's a magic beanie
foreign